this is really interesting but also not
really surprising because when we watch
presidential debates including the
recent Democratic primary debates on NBC
and CNN respectively the obvious
realization that anyone who watches
should come to if they're paying
attention is that there are narratives
that the network's are deliberately
pushing there are storylines that the
network's
and their moderators will just crowbar
into the debates and the network's are
not playing sort of a bystander role of
just facilitating the debate as
moderators as the term moderator would
suggest they're active participants
they're writing the storyline and before
the CNN debate I believe it was there
were all sorts of teasers and promos on
social media and on on CNN's website
about will Beto confront Pete Buddha
judge or vice versa about something and
it was just such a completely fabricated
and bogus narrative suggesting that the
big thing everyone's looking forward to
is what's gonna happen when Beto and
Budaj square off that was a totally
fabricated narrative like no one cared
about that but it was a storyline
created by corporate media and the
network clearly goes in with a plan this
is not just CNN to create confrontations
they set up candidates to respond
directly to often inaccurately framed
quotes from other candidates they try to
force disagreements they try to get
someone to attack somebody else and it's
so obvious and it's so brazen that it's
actually pathetic if you understand
what's going on they reinforce the
polling by giving the people who are
leading more time to talk and in a sense
I understand that but it becomes very
transparently a sensational when you
realize that they basically reinforce
the polling in terms of speaking time
except if there's a storyline that they
want to push that benefits from giving a
lower polling candidate more airtime for
example if a lower polling candidate
goes in and is just aggressively
attacking others that's going to get
them more speaking
time then their polling might suggest
because it's all sensationalized okay
that's the setup
so Andrew yang was on the h3 podcast the
other day and straight-up said it's even
more rigged than we thought and honestly
there's no reason to question this
whatsoever because it makes perfect
sense it confirms what seems pretty
obvious when you watch the debates take
a look at this you know one thing I'll
share with you all is that some of the
campaigns are in touch with the TV
network ahead of time to talk about what
sort of attack they want to stage there
like an attack on and around yes this
question would be would play really well
oh yes
the campaign says hey we're gonna make
this attack against Biden and in the
network I was okay like we get it and
then they help create that opportunity
what a nightmare I mean what a farce
yeah it's it's quite a disaster and I
want to share with you the perspectives
like I'm I think like a lay person who
happens to find himself on the
presidential debate stage being like
what the hell conference call yes so
this is just not surprising I mean how
many problems are there with the debates
that we've talked about problem number
one the format just doesn't let us learn
anything about what the candidates
really would do important policy
questions are expected to be answered in
30 seconds
sometimes rebutted in 15 seconds it's
laughable and the problem is a lot of
people can sound ok in 30 seconds but
really know nothing in depth so it's
actually a disservice to figuring out
who knows what they're talking about
second problem there are too many
candidates that will get solved soon
that's not really CNN or NBC's fault
that that's just a problem that's going
to be solved soon problem number three
the debates are as Andrew yang is saying
rigged to set up candidates for attacks
or kill shots at the expense of
substantive debate number four as you
know I've talked about debates need to
be public domain
okay we're picking the president or who
is going to run for president these
cannot be for profit events to be
monopolized by one network this hurts us
as you know we wanted to do commentary
on the CNN debate they
down on YouTube they gave us a copyright
strike their VP of who knows what was
attacking me on Twitter so that's bad
but it also allows the network's to turn
it into a boxing match effectively
rather than an important public service
and this is not just the network's
obviously the networks are going to do
it but the DNC the RNC the Commission on
Presidential Debates they could all say
we are not going to be complicit we will
insist on a format that is actually
better for figuring out who knows what
and their positions on issues we are
going to insist as a prerequisite that
these be effectively public domain
events like the State of the Union
address so yeah the networks will do
what's best for them and for ratings and
for clips and we know that but the DNC
RNC and Commission on presidential
debates are also complicit in it and
that needs to change so love that Andrew
yang is just saying it the way it is not
surprising it seemed pretty obvious just
from watching the debates that this is
what was going on but be that as it is
this is what we're dealing with and
these are not events that really let us
figure out who would be best at solving
issues for the country who is most
knowledgeable in any sort of depth
beyond one or two talking points on any
of these issues and it's been a complete
disservice to the democratic process as
I've been telling you
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom / Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinka samay zhing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by
going to blink is calm / Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube use the link
in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n